alright let's take some phone calls we
are going to start taking phone calls at
6 1 7 8 30 40 750 let's go to the caller
from the 571 area code it's always a
mystery when we start caller are you
able to hear me let's start there yet
you are awesome who's calling and where
you calling from uh Grover from Virginia
awesome what's on your mind uh some
questions so I I saw about the AMA
non-contiguous Yammer sometime how the
opening and you've been saying that I'm
machines are gonna take over the jobs
what can we do cuz I'm actually scare
I'm not a cashier but like I know sooner
or later what I'm doing will be taking
my machine well what are you doing to do
to solve that problem I'm up artistic
nation right so eventually i'm guessing
you're thinking that machines are going
to be able to do a lot of the work that
you're doing in terms of sort of like
the pre-work of getting it medications
dispensed in and bought packaged in that
type of thing is that your sense yet
yeah you know i think you're probably
right and in terms of what like what can
you personally do this at the personal
level what people can do is basically
look up what jobs are less likely to be
automated and there's a lot of tools on
the internet that will let you do this
and it'll tell you how likely is it that
your job is going to be automated
eventually and one option is you can try
to move into a field where your job is
less likely to be automated but the
thing is Grover that really we need a
paradigm shift in terms of how we see
our relationship to work and unless we
see that change in universal basic
income is one way that we would sort of
adapt to that coming change there's only
so much the individual can do because
let's say everybody tried to move into a
field that was less automatable well
then there's going to be an oversupply
of people looking to work in those
fields in that that that'll work for
some people but not everybody so I think
the solution has to come at a much
higher level and I don't know about you
but I'm sort of scared that nobody's
really taking that seriously right now
yes I also remembered I want to do
videos I think this is a Netherlands so
I remember which Europe yeah they were
putting people into the other people who
didn't have jobs and then the golden was
paying them and you said that going to
fail I didn't follow up on that video I
nah don't think you have follow-up and I
did it too but like Adam um well I don't
think those that's also the answer to
like get that goal in Japan the check to
everybody yeah I mean it's it depends on
how you think about it also you know
universal basic income is also being
thought of as a way to replace uh
various types of welfare programs that
are cobbled together in a more efficient
way so I think there's a number of
advantages to it i'll follow up on that
bill thank you so much for the call I
really really appreciate it